-October 11th is
National Coming Out Day,
when the LGBTQ community
celebrates
the brave act of coming out.
But one thing the community
isn't celebrating lately
is the disappearance
of lesbian bars.
According to
"Smithsonian" magazine,
there are only 15 left
in the whole country.
One of our writers, Jenny Hagel,
is a lesbian
and she decided to investigate.
[ Mid-tempo jazz plays ]
-Hey!
I'm Jenny Hagel,
and I'm here at
Henrietta Hudson,
New York's
longest-running lesbian bar.
I'm going to talk to the owner,
Lisa Cannistraci --
-Hey, what's up?
-...about why our bars
are disappearing.
But, first, because they're
disappearing so fast,
before we talk,
I have to inspect the place
and make sure
it's still a lesbian bar.
Is that okay?
-Let's go.
-Alright.
Alright, let's see
what we got here.
We got beer. Check.
Queer insignia. Check.
Masculine light fixture.
Sturdily built and
well-sanded bar. Check.
Woman in an outfit that's
both stylish and comfortable.
Yeah. This checks out.
[ Sighs ] Okay?
Now that we have completed
our checklist
and established that this is,
in fact, a lesbian bar,
I want to ask you
a few questions.
That alright?
-Sure. Let's do it.
-So, tell me a little bit
about lesbian bars.
What role have they played
in the queer community?
-Sure.
Lesbian bars, gay bars,
queer bars, and those spaces
are a safe haven.
I know I've seen young
queer people walk into here,
into this space,
and they look around,
and it's their first time
in a queer bar.
And they sit down,
and you just literally see
their shoulders go down.
You see the exhale.
And you can just see
the transformation
right in front of you.
It's beautiful.
-I remember going into --
the very first time I went
to a lesbian bar.
And you don't realize
all the tiny ways
in which you adjust yourself,
as you walk through the world,
to try to fit in or
seem a little different.
-Yeah.
-A little, like, straighter.
A little more mainstream.
-Sure.
-And I felt like I, like,
sat down at the bar.
and all that washed off me.
And I was just --
-Yeah, yourself.
-My little gay self.
-Yeah.
It was raining the other day,
and I was walking with somebody,
and I put my umbrella up.
And I said, you know --
because it was one umbrella.
And I put my arm
around the person,
and I said,
"I remember, in the '80s,
it was the only time I could
put my arm around my girlfriend,
was when it was raining, because
you could get away with it.
You know?
-Here's
the million-dollar question.
Why are lesbian bars
disappearing?
-Because lesbians can assimilate
much more easily
into mainstream society.
For example, like, now they're
making out at Applebee's.
They really don't need to come
to the West Village anymore.
-They used to come here
to make out,
but now they can make out
at the food court.
They're making out at Cinnabon.
They're making out
at Orange Julius.
-Something like that.
-Right?
They're making out
at Panda Express.
-It's horrendous.
-Yeah.
And bad for business,
more importantly.
For those who don't know, can
you tell me what nesting is?
-So, nesting is
when two lesbians meet
and they hook up,
they make out at Applebee's,
and then they essentially
move in together,
and they stay home and
play Trivial Pursuit
and make pasta.
And it's very bad for business.
We don't like that.
-You're describing
my ideal night.
-Yeah.
So I never introduce people to
each other, even if they beg me.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-So, once they start nesting,
they start staying home
and they don't come here
and spend their money.
-It's not good.
But then, when they break up,
they drink every night,
so it's not that bad.
You know, it is a cycle.
[ Both laugh ]
-When you first opened
Henrietta's,
it was a lesbian bar.
-Sure.
Is that still
how you refer to it,
or has how you refer to the bar
evolved?
-It's evolved over the years.
Now, as the community's
getting bigger
and people are, like,
really in tune
and can be more specific
about how they identify,
we refer to ourselves
as a queer human bar
built by lesbians.
-That's great,
because nothing is stronger
than something
built by lesbians.
-That's true. Yep.
-[ Laughs ]
What's your favorite
pick-up line?
-"Oh, hey, can I have a kiss?"
-[ Laughs ]
That's very direct.
-Yeah.
It's actually worked a lot
in the '90s.
-So, I'm just going to write,
"Can I have a kiss?"
If you had to estimate --
the bar's been open 30 years --
how many breakups do you think
have happened
inside these walls?
-I've gotten a lot of
"thank yous" for relationships
that started here.
-Aww, that's great.
-With families
and stuff like that.
I don't get a lot of e-mails
about the breakups.
-[ Laughs ]
They should be required.
They should be required to
register their breakup with you.
Well, Lisa, this has been great.
So, now that you've helped me
understand some of the issues
going on around lesbian bars,
I want to see if I can help you.
Does that sound good?
-Sure.
-Great. Let's head to the bar.
-Let's do it.
-Go ahead.
-Okay, so, just to end
on a fun note,
I really want there to be more
lesbian bars in the world.
So, just in case someone is
thinking about opening one,
but they don't have,
like, the right name,
I have come up with a few names
for lesbian bars.
Just possible names.
And you're the expert.
So I'm going to
show them to you,
and you tell me
if these are good names.
-Let's do it.
-Queer Goggles.
-Maybe in Britain.
-LGBTGI Fridays.
-[ Chuckles ] Aah.
-No?
-Nah.
-It doesn't roll --
A little too clumsy
on the tongue?
-You forgot the "Q."
-I did that.
You're exactly right.
Okay, now this is, like,
for if you're going to open
in an Irish bar.
-Sure.
-Flannelgans.
-Ooh, yes.
-Yes? Great.
-Park Slope.
-Park Slope. Exactly.
Alright. Oh, man.
Your Ex-Girlfriend is
Probably in Here.
-I think that's
the name of this place.
-It probably is
the name of this place?
-Yeah, in parentheses, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
Lady Cheers.
It's like Cheers,
but for ladies.
-Not feeling it.
-Not feeling it?
-Nah.
-Alright. You know what?
I'll meet you at Flannelgans.
-Absolutely. Let's do it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Pitchers.
-Alright, so, Lisa,
you just renovated your bar
and reopened it.
And I want the relaunch
to go great.
So I've come up with
a few drink specials
that I think you could offer
to drum up business.
So I'm just gonna
show them to you.
And then you tell me
what you think of them, okay?
-Sure.
-Okay.
-Let's do it.
-Alright. The Cartini.
It's a martini
served in a glass Subaru.
Like, it's sporty, but
it will get you drunk.
-I'm thinking -- Yeah, as a --
maybe a big one in, like,
a sharing, like a bowl.
-Great.
-Yeah, I'm in.
-Yeah? Good.
This is the First Date.
It's a bourbon and a lease.
-Ooh.
That would go over very well.
-Right?
-Yes.
-Alright.
And finally,
the Tegan and Sara.
it's just two identical drinks.
-Love it.
-Yeah?
-You know why?
-Why?
-You get to ring up
two drinks at once.
-There you go.
See, this is your profit margin.
-We're putting that on the menu
immediately.
-Great. Alright.
-I love it. That's great.
-I'm in. Can I --
I think -- Did I just get hired
as a bartender?
-Um, sure, as a fill-in.
-A fill-in. Okay, right.
I have to work my way up.
I understand.
Okay, that's fair.
-Fantastic.
-Great.
-You're in.
-Hey, thank you so much
for talking to me today.
I really appreciate it.
And if you live
near a lesbian bar,
please consider supporting it.
And if you don't live
near a lesbian bar,
consider opening one,
and letting me and Lisa
drink there for free.
-Yes.
Thank you.
-Jenny Hagel, everybody.
And thanks to Lisa Cannistraci
at Henrietta Hudson
for welcoming us into her bar.